in mikalayan daylight revealed the
extent of damage from the overnight
missile strikes
emergency workers in this Southern
Ukrainian City discovering more civilian
targets as they searched for residents
in need of help buried under the rubble
of this apartment building an 11 year
old child
digging the boy out took six hours
he later died
as NATO defense ministers met for a
second day in Brussels deliberating on
how to deal with Russia and better arm
Ukraine President Vladimir zielinski
asked the alliance for more help saying
Ukraine has only about 10 percent of
what it needs for its air defenses
we want to have a possibility to close
this car our capabilities are not enough
Germany opened up the way to this
possibility by providing the first rst
system the United States of America
confirmed its support business sums we
would like a lot for this support to be
much bigger
at the conclusion of the meeting NATO
Secretary General Jen stoltenberg
pledged the alliance's full support for
Kiev and described the comprehensive
assistance package including drone
equipment and drone jammers
the big question though how NATO would
respond to the use of any nuclear
weapons by Russia we will not go into
exactly how we will respond but of
course this will fundamentally change
the nature of the conflict it will it
will
mean that a very important line has been
closed
even any use of a smaller nuclear weapon
will be a very serious thing a
fundamentally changing the nature of the
war in Ukraine and of course that will
have consequences in Ukraine many wonder
what exactly those consequences will be
but it's not just the nuclear threat
ukrainians are concerned about
Air Raid Sirens once again rang out
across the country including here in
leviv on Thursday many are worried that
Russia will increasingly Target civilian
infrastructure temperatures are already
dropping and the prospect of a winter
without access to electricity is leaving
residents very much on edge